the prime minister might say he and the
public want to get brexit done
but there are plenty of people who
disagree entirely on the opening day of
this conservative party conference
thousands turned out in heavy rain to
demonstrate their anger
against boris johnson he has his own
gender and he's not listening to
the people practically the north in the
north it's like
we don't vote for you you don't
represent us
and we just want to get with you johnson
has a strategy now of saying brexit is a
matter
of people versus parliaments that mps
are blocking the will of the people to
deliver brexit
the trouble is that argument doesn't
really work in manchester
in some ways it's quite a controversial
choice for the conservatives to try to
hold their conference in manchester
there are five mps in this city they're
all labour
people here don't like the conservatives
they don't like boris johnson
i don't really like brexit either
johnson is trying to keep a grip on the
agenda visiting a hospital to publicize
a policy
or putting more money into health care
but what he can't
or won't explain is how he will ensure
the uk leaves the eu
at the end of october while
simultaneously obeying a law passed in
parliament
that says he's not allowed to without an
agreement
what we are going to do is work very
hard to get a deal
and then
if we can't uh we will make sure that we
come out on october
the 31st but probably better if i
focus on getting the deal rather than
discussing
the hypothesis of what happens if we
if we can't it isn't only the protesters
who are on the move
over the coming days while the
conference is sitting opposition mps are
likely to finalize plans
to bring johnson down in a vote of
confidence looking like he's in charge
is no easy task for this prime minister
lawrence lee al-jazeera manchester